I want to start today with intelligence
and Cirie we're going to start in my
bedroom when when I woke up in the
morning and you'll notice because my
phone knows that in the morning I like
to meditate that it's offered me a
meditation app right here in the bottom
left of the screen so I can just swipe
up from the bottom left and I'm taken
right into meditate this is so serene so
I want to jump forward to later today
when I think I'll be reminiscing about
wwd sees past and I can ask Siri to help
me with that show my photos from last
June in San Francisco oh yeah this is
great all these photos from WWDC and you
notice now photos in iOS 9 us this great
scrubber bar down at the bottom so i can
easily slide through photos super
quickly just like this let's see oh boy
now we're into the karaoke night when I
want to get really pumped up and
inspired for karaoke night I like to
turn to my Eddie karaoke album so let's
do that now show my karaoke photos of
Eddie oh that is the master at work
hitting all I love this hat well I could
really look at these just all day but
you know actually my assistant has given
me a reminder based on traffic
conditions that it's time to leave so
I'm going to wrap up this demo of
intelligence an iOS 9